(upbeat music)
- Hello, welcome to another
episode of the Addy Hour.
It's my pleasure to welcome you all back.
And I'm really honored today to host
what I think is a really
timely conversation,
especially as we're getting ready
on several college campuses
and university campuses
across the nation to go
back to our fall semester.
Obviously, this is a fall
semester that, again, is different
from what we've experienced before.
And so I think today's
conversation is very timely
as we think about campus life,
as we think about mental health and faith
in our ongoing pandemic world.
And I'm grateful for the guests
who are joining me today,
these individuals that
I've known for a few years
and have been able to interact with
and partner with in different ways.
And so I'm excited to be
able to share their words
with all of you and I'm
really looking forward
to our conversation and the
wisdom that I know they're going
to share with all of us as well.
So the first guest I'd like to introduce
is Chaplain Sharon Kugler, and
Sharon has been the chaplain
at Yale University since 2007.
She came to New Haven from
Johns Hopkins University
in Baltimore, where she had served
as the university chaplain since 1993.
She has three decades of
experience in ministry
in higher education and
interfaith collaboration
and in pastoral and social ministry.
Her main focus at Yale has
been cultivating chaplaincy
for students, faculty, and
staff, which defines itself
by serving the needs of the
richly diverse religious
and spiritual traditions on campus,
allowing for deeper dialogue,
increased accessibility,
personal growth, creative
educational opportunities,
and pastoral leadership.
And Sharon is also one who has served
in several different leadership roles
in national chaplaincy organizations.
So I'm grateful and honored
to welcome Sharon Kugler
to the Addy Hour podcast today.
Thanks so much for being here.
- It's my pleasure.
It really is.
- The second guest I
would like to introduce,
is Orlando Yarborough III.
Orlando is a scientist,
certified leadership coach,
consultant, speaker, and trainer.
He coaches and trains a
diverse international portfolio
of young professionals,
academics, and community,
and business leaders
in leader development,
professional and communication
skills and personal growth.
He also pastors the Black Church at Yale,
also known as BCAY,
which is a student-run
church on Yale's campus
that has been in existence since 1972.
Dr. Orlando is a Meyerhoff
scholar who holds a BA in Biology
and Africana studies from
the University of Maryland,
Baltimore County and a PhD in
genetics from Yale University.
He also holds certificates
in marriage counseling
and pastoral leadership, and is certified
as a Maxwell DISC Method
behavioral consultant
and Maxwell parenting and family guide.
So deeply honored to
welcome Orlando Yarborough
to the Addy Hour podcast as well.
Thanks for being here, Orlando.
- Thank you.
It's my honor to be here.
- The third guest, which
I'd like to introduce
is Omer Bajwa, who is the
director of Muslim life
in the chaplain's office at
Yale, and who has been engaged
in religious service and
inter-religious engagement
and educational outreach since 2000.
He holds degrees and has a certificate
in Islamic chaplaincy.
He also has an MA in Near Eastern Studies
and an MS In communications.
He is someone who has studied
several classical Islamic
sciences with traditional
scholars from Pakistan, Turkey,
and the United States.
His interests include
Islam in the United States
and the intersections of culture, media,
politics, and spirituality.
He regularly lectures about these topics
and others around the country
and he is also the co editor
of a forthcoming book
"Mantle of Mercy: Islamic
Chaplaincy in North America".
So thank you Omer for also being here
and joining us on the
Addy hour podcast today.
- Thank you, it's a profound privilege.
Thank you.
- Well, again, I'm grateful
to all of you for being here.
I just have to start by
saying how grateful I am
for the work that you all do on campus,
investing in students and
really walking with them
in their spiritual journeys
and especially with all the topics
that we're going to be
talking about today.
Obviously, that's always important work
and even so much more
so, and all of the things
that we're experiencing as a
society these days as well.
And even before we start, I
think, we're gonna be talking
about important topics, but
also just want to, of course,
acknowledge that there are
challenges that are going on
all over the world sometimes
things that get more press
and other times, obviously,
the events in Afghanistan.
But just acknowledging that
these challenges are things
that are going on on an ongoing basis
and wants to be just acknowledging
and cognizant of that,
even as we're having the
conversation today too.
But knowing that this is in
the context of that as well.
I just wanted to make sure
that our audiences knows
that we're thinking about
those things as well
and just the challenges and suffering
that lots of people are
going through in many ways.
At the same time, it also
gives me hope, just being here
on this screen, on the
airways with all of you
and knowing that we're all in
this fight and this struggle
and this joy of life together.
So with that, just want to
start out as I often do,
just checking in with all of you
to see how you're doing these days.
This is obviously, again,
another unique semester
that we're entering into
on our college campuses.
And just want to see how
you all are doing overall,
both in your personal
lives and in your roles
and interactions with students.
So Sharon, if we could start with you.
- Sure, thank you.
I think, I wanna first
say, I ended last semester
as exhausted as I think I'd ever been
in my professional career.
Just, what's the expression?
Tired to the bone.
And so the month of July,
I took a technology break
and that was very helpful
to step away from the email,
still doing some work, but
just really putting a pause
on Zoom and all those things
because I was frankly nervous
about the next year,
about this new semester
that starts in just two
weeks, and that did help.
It made a difference
and it gave me a chance
to have some meditative time.
And I've been doing a lot of thinking
about what our students have experienced,
how they're trying to make sense
of what they're coming back to.
The anxiety levels are
very high everywhere,
but especially with young
adults, it's we know this,
the studies have shown the
increase in these challenges.
So I am also aware that
I can't fix it all,
it's not my role to fix it all,
but I can witness it and tell the truth.
That's what I'm trying to do.
We had a staff retreat last week,
a day-long retreat together.
Omer was there and part of
the theme of the retreat
was there's healing in the return.
And so we're talking about that.
That's the words of the Buddhist
teacher, Sharon Salzberg.
And what does it mean to
return and what does it mean
to be part of that healing?
So that's kind of where my
head and my heart is right now,
as we look to the fall.
- Well, thanks for your honesty
and I appreciate you sharing
that reflection time as well
and the ways that you were
identifying with your students
and understanding what
they're going through,
what we're all going through.
I'm curious if it was
difficult to pull away,
even at the beginning, even
as you had set that in motion,
how did that process come about?
- Well, you really have to give
yourself permission to do it
because honestly, it's muscle memory.
I mean, I don't sleep with
my phone on the bed table.
That is one flight of stairs away
and that's been a good
habit that I've kept...
Really, I've kept that up ever
since I've had a smartphone
and it's made a difference so
that I don't have that reflex
when I wake up in the morning.
But it's the first thing I
pick up when I go downstairs.
So I had to really pay attention to that
and also ask myself the question
when I'm opening my computer,
what is it that you're doing?
Are you writing something great?
Are you reading something
that's been written
and isn't sort of a social media thing?
Awesome. (laughing)
So I would say it took probably four days
to (mumbles) discipline.
- Yeah. Yeah.
I think that's helpful to hear as well.
I mean, even as you're describing
the phone being a flight
of stairs away, I'm sure
many people kind of recoil,
oh, ooh, just kinda that,
wow, can the phone
really be that far away?
What if I miss something important?
So I think you're exactly right.
And it sounds like, in a way
you've you set up a discipline.
But even with that, it sounds
like it still took time.
So I think that's really important
that you were able to do that.
I think that's a good
principle too 'cause I know
with students that I've interacted with,
that's been something
we've talked about a lot,
just giving yourself that time.
The tendency is to day one
say, "Oh, I couldn't do it.
It didn't work."
And then to get stuck and then
just start to beat oneself up
and kind of get stuck in the cycle.
So I appreciate your candor in that too
and taking us through
that process as well, so.
What about you, Orlando?
How's the process been for
you in terms of everything
that we've experienced
as you're getting ready
for the fall semester?
- Yes, thank you.
At the beginning of August,
I got a chance to take a technology break
and spend time with family
in a different state.
And that was refreshing.
It wasn't planned, so I don't necessarily
say planned technology
breaks though I should,
but this was one by circumstance
and it just helped me
to be in the moment, to
be present and to say,
okay, I'm away and I can connect
in a different way with people.
I think as I enter this
semester, in terms of my role
as pastor of BCAY, I'm worn
and we haven't even started.
And I think I'm worn in terms of strategy.
I don't necessarily know
that there's an expectation
for leadership to have answers,
but certainly the time
where you need a leader
is during the time when
there's a lot of uncertainty.
And I'm just recognizing
that I can't plan that far ahead and...
Yes, can't play that for ahead,
maybe not even a couple of weeks ahead
and I don't have all the answers.
And so the question is,
what are the values?
Or what are the principles?
What are the spiritual
practices or even the goals
that I may wanna hold on to
and may want to encourage our members
and our students to hold to?
So I think in terms of being
a strategic leader, I'm worn
because I'm not coming up
with long-term strategy
and I think that's appropriate
for me not to do so.
We've seen that long-term
planning doesn't stay.
And at the same time, I
am hopeful and challenged
about the idea of having
spiritual community on campus
or spiritual community that's connected
with the academic start of the year.
If there's any time to bring
a wholeness to who I am,
to who our communities are,
this is the time to do it.
So I think my being a part
of this work and being a part
of the larger fabric of Yale University,
and of campus ministry,
we're made for this time.
And so that gives me a lot
of hope and encouragement.
And I'm looking forward
to just being the person
for this hour and connecting
with other people,
with students who are
the people for this hour.
- That's really encouraging to hear.
And I appreciate your level
of transparency as well.
And I think I'm sure this has
likely been your experience
by offering me that level of transparency
is healing in a sense
too, as our students know
that we don't have all the answers
and as they hear us
walking through it as well,
and as they see us also leaning
on each other and on them
as community members,
and as you talked about
the spirit of community,
I think that goes such a long way.
And I think Glod Jr. was
on the podcast previously
a couple of weeks ago and one
thing that he talked about,
which you reminded me about
was just the wholeness
that can come from brokenness as well,
because he talked about
the wholeness of community,
but not to say that there
aren't cracks in the jar,
so to speak, as he mentioned.
And so even as you are
trying to figure out
what the strategies look like,
you haven't figured it all out,
but you're able to lean on
community and to have a sense
of wholeness with the
community in that space.
And I think that's really powerful.
And I would imagine that
your students get strength
from that as well as they see
you walk through that journey.
So I appreciate you sharing that.
- Yes, thank you.
Omer, what about for you?
- Thank you to-
- (mumbles) and reengaging.
- My friends and colleagues,
it's just fantastic answers.
I think for me, there's been
sort of this juxtaposition
or this tension almost between
two overriding feelings.
One is, to be very honest amongst friends,
in many ways I felt myself really
in the last year and a half
able to breathe, right,
with just the forced slow down, right?
The nature of our work in the academy,
in these spaces, in academic
spaces, in community spaces
is that we're always on.
And I just felt like
for me, very personally,
I spent a lot more quality
time with my family.
I was able to revisit a lot
of my spiritual disciplines
and practices that I had that sort of
that way you wanna get back into.
And then, of the blessings I
would say of that is I had time
where the outside world was shut off
and then I got to do writing,
which I'd always wanted to do
when I sat down with my friends
and we worked on this
book project together,
which is forthcoming, as
you mentioned, thank you.
And so that in that way,
I feel incredibly grateful
and blessed to the almighty
for everything that I got.
At the same time, I'm
mindful of the world has been
and continues to be a place of deep sorrow
and tension and brokenness
as we've witnessed
at so many levels.
But at a personal level right
now too, is I am full of,
as Orlando said too, the
uncertainty of the fall semester,
like I'm just finding
myself day after day,
we're getting closer to the
opening of the semester.
And I just have this unease
and anxiety with like the unknown,
like, what's it gonna be like?
And I understand things keep
changing, we have to be nimble,
we have to be flexible
with this, but I mean,
what I think a year ago
where I was feeling,
it was very different place.
But thank you for asking.
- Well, that's encouraging
to hear as well,
just a refreshment and as
you've named, just the tension
that's still there as well.
I'm also curious if you talked
about some of the spiritual
disciplines and the writing
you've been able to do,
even amidst the anxiety
that you're feeling
as we all come back to campus, in a sense.
How do you anticipate
those moving forward?
Do you think those disciplines will stick?
Are you starting to...
Are you gonna see how it goes?
It sounds like you had
the space to create them.
And is that space gonna still
be there as you go forward?
'Cause I imagine that's
something that a lot of students
will be thinking about as well.
- Yeah. No, thank you.
I mean, that's the million dollar question
that I ask myself every day, right?
Is that I want to...
There's days when I think
I got this, I can do this,
I can maintain it.
Once you be healthy, once you
be balanced, how they do it.
There's other days where I'm just like,
oh no, something's got to get jettisoned
over the edge, right, of
the ship to keep it upright.
So (mumbles) go back
and forth day after day.
But I'd like to think I'm surrounded
by incredibly supportive
people that one of the things
that I've sort of tried to
remind myself throughout this
is that no man is an
island, right, so to speak.
I can't do it alone.
All of the support that I've
had has come from family,
friends, colleagues that has allowed me
to flourish in my own way, so.
And I'm going to be mindful of that.
And so it's just about shifting,
we're gonna re-engage
with community, right?
With our friends, with our
colleagues, with our students.
And so it's about re-navigating that.
- Yup, right.
Yeah. Yeah.
I really appreciate that
and reminds me of what Sharon
mentioned too, in this topic
that you all had talked
about in the return,
the coming back and the returning.
And I'm curious if any of you
are willing to share some of,
if there are any principles
that have come out
of those discussions, even the retreat
that you all had together
in terms of ways to return,
or maybe things to try and be aware of
along any of these aspects in
terms of spiritual practices,
in terms of mental health,
just in terms of navigation.
So anyone that's willing
to kind of share maybe some
of the conversations around that.
- I think Omer and Orlando
both touched upon this
in different ways,
but we're living with
contradictions, right?
So there's the built-in
kind of anxiety and worry
that we feel of the unknown.
And we've been living with
the unknown for so long now
that sometimes the word
doesn't even have the power
that we know it actually has,
but we just sort of glide over it.
There's so much unknown.
Well, that means there's so much loss.
There's so much uncertainty,
these are all big, heavy things.
At the same time, there
are also these joys
that are they're dancing
in the middle of it too,
we're seeing each other again,
we're planning for our kind of a future.
We're not sure what it's gonna look like,
but we're trying to put our
heads together and figure out
how can we pull off this ritual?
How can we do this or that?
And that I think is feeding us,
but I think what came out of our retreat
and certainly Omer, please chime in,
was also just a willingness to say,
there's just a lot of mess ahead.
And we have to be kind to
ourselves and each other
as we sort of trump through it.
And that's just us, the adults.
So you can imagine how
students are going to be.
And they live a life that
is a lot faster paced.
I was just talking with
a friend the other day
about students on their phones
are having probably five
or six different kinds of conversations
with different individuals in their lives
all at the same time.
They could be texting
with a family member,
they could be texting with a
professor, with two friends,
with somebody they wanna be friends with.
And then they're also filming themselves
and they're doing all
kinds of other things.
And so there's a different
energy that students have
as they walk through the
world that we as chaplains
and imams and ministers are witnessing
and trying to help them also step back
and kind of gain an
agency over themselves.
And so I think about the
beginning of the school year,
and normally our offices would be crowded
with students coming by to
say hello and get an ice cream
and all those things.
And now, we're gonna be there,
but we're gonna be masked
and they can't loiter and...
(laughing)
It's all gonna be a kind of
messy, albeit loving something.
And we just don't quite
know what it'll be,
but what I'm most excited
about is providing some kind
of soft landing for these
students that are processing
so much both in their personal lives,
but also in their
academic and social lives.
So yeah.
- Wow. That was really well said.
And even though it was probably not meant
as a profound word, even
the way you just said it,
it'll be something.
(laughing)
I think that that captures
it, all the different pieces
and all the elements.
We don't know what all
of that will look like,
but it will still be something
and that something will
still be meaningful.
- Yeah, if I may, just one
more thing, I think that,
and I appreciate you
catching that, as a leader,
I'm often asked questions that
I just don't have answers to
and I feel horrible about it.
But I do know there will be something.
(laughing)
- That's so true.
- Yeah.
- Omer, anything you want to add there
from your perspective?
- Yeah, no, thank you, Sharon.
Fantastic.
Very little to add.
I mean, I think one of the thoughts
that I keep coming back to,
and we talked about
their treat as well is...
And I'm guilty of this as well, right?
The language of, when are
we gonna return to normal?
When will things go back to normal?
Like normal classes,
normal social interactions
and all of that.
And look, just as much as the next person,
I'm pining for that, right?
But I think, one of the
things that I remind myself
is to just really shift the
lens in a sense that say,
well, of the many lessons
that maybe the pandemic
and the global slowdown
has taught us is that
what was normal before and
normal may have worked for some,
but it didn't work for many, right?
In terms of race relations,
in terms of healthcare,
in terms of education, in
terms of predatory economies,
and the list goes on and on, right?
And so, I mean, I don't have
the answer except to say that,
is that the normal I wanna go back to?
Or can we try to create a
different normal or world, right?
That's something that this
idea of healing and return
as we're being invited
to return to a semblance
of life together.
And how do we heal, right?
The fractures as the last
year has taught us, right?
With the massive social upheavals
and we're witnessing sort
of horrible climate change
that's accelerating in front of our eyes
and the list goes on, right?
I just try to...
I mean, I try to, at least with my kids,
we try to talk about
this from time to time,
is that they're all geared up.
We're going back to school.
It's gonna be normal again.
Well, let's slow down and think about
what does normal mean for you and I?
what does it mean for
people around the world?
So I just put that out there.
- Yeah, that's a really important point.
And what the new normal will look like.
To follow up with that a little bit,
I'm curious from the lens
from all three of you,
what you've seen shift
in terms of campus life
since the pandemic started
and what you're seeing shift
for the good and what you've
seen maybe shift for the bad
and ways that we're
trying to address that.
Orlando, maybe we can start with you
if you have any perspectives there.
- Yes, I think a positive shift
might be a greater
appreciation for relationships,
a greater appreciation
for who's in front of you.
I can imagine students not
wanting to break apart (laughing)
end their evening conversation
or leave the group
that they're a part of.
I can imagine some professors
just really appreciating
more deeply being in the classroom
and interacting with students.
There's a ease to being in
person in terms of communication,
in terms of timing that we
can take breaths together
and that we can pause and people
can still follow each other
in terms of what's being thought
or what's being communicated.
And so I think there's gonna
be a heightened appreciation
for being onsite and in the
presence of one another.
And I also think on the
challenges side, there might be...
I think dependencies may come out.
I think there may be some
unhealthy revelations of behavior
or desires that will
allow healing to then come
because of that revelation.
But I think that's going to come out.
Something during the pandemic,
many people on campus felt isolated
because even though they were on campus,
they weren't necessarily all together.
And so you take two isolated
people who want to be together
and they're hanging out
maybe more than they should,
or there's increased desire.
So I think there'll be a
little maybe overcompensation
or overcorrection in terms
of what happened last year,
what's been happening over the
summer and the opportunities
that will present
themselves this coming year.
I think it will be mostly positive
and everything will be an
opportunity for further growth.
- Yeah, and again, I
keep isolating that word,
but I think growth is so well
set on that aspect as well
because even as you talked
about some of the positives
and some of the areas
where there'll be tensions
and opportunities for learning,
it seems like that is exactly what it is.
And then to go back to what Sharon said,
to have grace for some of those missteps
or challenges along the way
and to make sure there's room
for that 'cause it's a journey
that we're all in together.
Definitely appreciate you
sharing both of those insights.
- Thank you, yeah.
- And then, I mean, you've
also, as we've been talking,
you've all of you and myself included,
I think we can all relate
to the anxiety component
that's been there and classmates
we talked about anxiety
kind of that creeps up when
there is either something
that's unknown or a perception
of things being unknown.
And there's a lot of true
to that in this moment
that we're in right now.
So also, in your
interactions with students,
I'm curious how you have
seen and how you've walked
with students in terms of
their emotional journeys
and their mental health.
How have you seen that play out?
I would anticipate that
it's been a mixture,
but would love to hear
how that process has been.
And then what you take
from those experiences
as you head into this new semester
and continue to think about
how you support students
in that way.
Omer, maybe we can start
with you this time around.
- Sure, thank you.
Two thoughts come to mind.
One is related to the point
is that students are so hungry
for community and connection, right?
I mean, literally, I open
my email every morning
and I've got a different student
undergrad, post-doc like,
"When are we gonna start
Friday prayers again on campus?
When can we see each other?
When is the student life aspect
of campus gonna pick up again?"
And the answer is always,
"I don't know, but God willing, soon
and let's just be patient."
Right?
And I think that relates
to the second point
about the mental health is that I think
there aren't any easy answers to this
to navigate with students.
But the thing that I have
really been able to stress
in a lot of my one-on-ones
with students and that's,
in my mind, one of the
interesting sort of things
that I discovered with this
is that I'm all about in-person
interaction being present,
being present with the other person.
But I found myself doing a
lot more one-on-ones, right,
with students and community
members during this.
And one of the things that's
come out is, in a strange way,
we've been able to go deeper, right,
in some of these sessions and with that,
ones that are struggled
with mental health,
I've been able to really spend
time and I'm not a therapist,
I make that very clear, right?
But to be able to refer them to sources.
And I think it's gotten
them thinking, right,
that they have this...
Because they've slowed down,
it's almost like that space
has been created in their
life and in their work life
to be like, "Yeah, I've
kind of put this off
and I'm really struggling and I need this.
I need to find someone.
So can you help me find
someone or what to do
or what to read or who to talk to.
And that has been sort of a
pleasant surprise, I may say,
from this in my experience.
- That's great to hear
and refreshing as well
and appreciate you being there.
It seems like you've
helped facilitate that
as well as a combination
of both the circumstance
and the openness to it.
So that's really, really powerful.
Sharon, what about you
from your perspective
as the lead chaplain, in a
sense, and what the oversight
that you have and the
interactions with students?
- Well, I have to say, certainly,
our schedules really were
much more busy, much fuller.
We were going at a slower
pace, but we were going,
I felt like at a fuller
gate with the amount
of students we were seeing over Zoom.
And one of the things that
became really clear early on,
these were students that I did not know
that were reaching out because
they felt something was off
for them or they were frightened
about how they were feeling.
And we were able to get
to the heart of the matter
so much more quickly.
And it only occurred to
me that that was happening
maybe about halfway into
the year where I'm thinking,
wow, they didn't even know me.
And when I asked a sort of open question,
they would go right in.
And so what that made me think
about was the distractions
in my office, the things that
could buy time before getting
to the heart of the
matter, whether it's...
I have a snow globe collection
and I have goofy little windup toys.
And I thought to myself,
yeah, they only had just this
to look at.
And so I have thought about
keeping some hours open
over Zoom so that people
could make an appointment.
Let's say they just didn't feel
like walking across campus,
but they wanna talk to somebody.
And so I do...
We've talked about this as a staff.
We are gonna hang on to some of that.
A couple other colleagues
in our office did anti-racists book groups
and they had people coming
to these book groups
that would never have been able to do it,
but they just had to push a
button and they were there
and they could eat their
lunch and then push the button
and go back to whatever they were doing.
And so we see some sort of
important aha moments in that,
that I think that the technology
that we're all forced to
use, isn't all that bad
in some cases.
(laughing)
And so there's that.
And I think specifically with
some of these conversations,
I can remember, oh my goodness,
the very first student
who made an appointment to see
me when we went into lockdown
and his first question was,
"Is this the end of the world?"
And in all my years in chaplaincy,
no one had asked me that
question quite that way.
And I said, "It's the end of a world."
And I felt like, gosh, I
hope I didn't freak him out
by saying that.
But I also felt it was
important to tell the truth.
And that's what I was
feeling in that moment.
And I think that's true that
it was the end of a world.
And so our work is, what does
this next world need to be
so that we are better
in it and better for it?
So these deep conversations,
some of them kind of
existential and broad,
and some of them just a
person is personally terrified
to leave their house have been present
in just such a high volume for all of us.
And I think the last thing
I'll say is just as the sort
of person that has to
keep everybody afloat
in terms of the other chaplains,
I just felt so humbled
by how we were, when one person was down,
someone else stepped in,
and it was just like...
We didn't choreograph it that
way, but I think all of us,
all the different religious
and spiritual organizations
just knew this is hard
and we have to keep going,
but we don't have to be perfect.
- It's so important.
And I'm encouraged just what the...
I mean, the theme that keeps
coming up is the opportunity
that's been there in a lot of ways.
And it's great to know that
you're keeping both of those
in-person and Zoom options available
to create more opportunity
in some ways as well.
- I think it will lead
us to important insights
into how other ways to do this work.
And honestly, the key has
always been, in ministry,
not to abandon.
Now we're in a situation
where we physically
couldn't be together, but
we had to think of ways
to help people not feel
like they were abandoned.
- Right.
- And that they're suffering alone.
And so, again, it was an imperfect thing,
but it did give us some stuff, I think,
that we have to pay attention to.
- Yeah.
Yeah.
And creative community.
I think even the way you've
described the students,
I mean, I feel like I
have to give them a lot
of encouragement and support
for just even taking advantage.
I mean, you said you're
hearing from students
that you never heard from before.
So taking a step out of a
comfort zone to reach out
and to connect, and it sounds
like those conversations
are going very deep pretty quickly.
So again, the opportunity in
that community and encouraging
to hear even the way
amongst the chaplains,
that you've been able to
step in for each other.
I think that speaks well
about your community as well
in the ways that you all
are supporting each other
in these different ways, so.
Orlando for you as a pastor
of the Black Church of Yale,
have you seen some of these
same principles at play?
Are there other ones that have come up
that we haven't quite touched on as well
in terms of the students'
emotional journeys
and just support around mental health?
- Yeah, so I'm seeing a lot of overlap.
I think for me, there's
been a dream come true,
something that I've desired
for many years, and that is
ongoing conversation
and just an opportunity
for a continuity of experience.
And over this pandemic,
it's been nice to be able
to have ongoing conversations
about a student's wellbeing
or about what they're thinking,
what they're experiencing,
what they're dreaming about,
or what their concern is
versus just you speak to somebody once
and you don't hear from them again.
And so something that I...
It's a desire because there's...
It's usually one-on-one
and so I'm trying to think,
well, how do we multiply this?
But is the opportunity
to really have someone
walk beside a student,
like a shepherd would walk beside sheep,
like someone really to take
them from one place to another
and be there for conversation,
be there for dialogue,
or just be there to listen,
which is mostly what happens.
Me being able to be quiet and
just hear and to ask questions
that will serve the student
and will help bring reflection
and revelation, but also
just maybe greater clarity
on where they are, or just the assurance
that you're not alone even if
you may feel that you're alone
in certain ways, I'm also here with you.
And then the second
thing that has happened
that I think Sharon has
really demonstrated,
so Sharon has this wonderful
opportunity to be a leader
of leaders, leading the
chaplain office chaplains,
but then also leading the larger group
of religious ministers on campus.
And something that Sharon has
done, at the end of semester,
I realized there was an
opportunity for myself.
So Sharon helps us to
get through the semester
and just helps us to say,
"Okay, this is what we're doing.
This is what needs to happen."
And after we get through the semester,
Sharon, you help us get through the year,
get through the rest of the year.
And it wasn't until the end of
last semester that I realized
that one of my goals or
one of the opportunities
that I had was just to
shepherd the students through
and to not lose any.
And if there is a principle,
maybe I'll call it the
Harriet Tubman Principle,
where you're leading a group
of people from one place
to another place, but you're helping them
to make that journey.
And so when I come into
this semester this year,
one of the things I'm
thinking about is like,
okay, how do I help the students
who have begun this journey
to make it to the next stage?
And they don't have to make it perfectly.
They don't have to make it
necessarily with all the goals
achieved that they've come
into the semester with.
But how do I help them to make it
and then cause them to look back and say,
"See how far I've come?"
And see that we've come together.
And that's a wonderful opportunity,
is a wonderful blessing
to be a part of that process.
And I think that's part
of something that helps
with mental health is being able to say,
"We've done it once, we can do it again."
Or, "Other people before me have done it.
Maybe I can do it too."
And that's something that I'm
looking forward to embracing
and honoring and cherishing
and rising to the occasion
to contribute to their own journeys
from one place to beginning place,
even if it's just the journey
from August to December
and then in January to May,
and then of course over the summer
because we're still with
them in so many ways.
- Yeah, that's so good and
it reverberates, as you said,
and as they're learning
from their own journeys
or looking to others as well and seeing
how that goes forward in
a lot of ways and my...
I'm trying not to go too
much into neuroscience,
but in some ways it thinks
about just the way our brain
is designed as well.
And the ways that our
brains respond to things
in our environment, how we're
really recreating those things
for us to perceive that.
I mean, people talk about the memory cells
and certain parts of the
brains in taxi drivers,
they're called mirror neurons,
which can kind of respond
to certain things in the environment.
And even just what you're
talking about is...
Might be getting too far outside
and making this parallel too
strong, but I'm just thinking
about the ways that we
can do that in our lives
and learn from that and grow from that
as communities as well.
And so, yeah, just encouraged
to hear that approach
and for what you see coming forward
in this new semester as well.
And I think you're all
highlighting some of the strengths,
it seems, that you all
have been able to galvanize
and that students have
also been using overall,
just in terms of emotional
wellness and mental health
and things that they
can use going forward.
Not to make things negative,
but I'm also curious if
there've been misperceptions
that you've run into.
And I bring that up
because I think sometimes
that can be clarifying to
speak about in larger contexts,
because I know in the events
that we've done in the past,
after we spoken about those
things in the public space,
people have said, "Oh, I've
been thinking about these things
for years, but I've never had
a place to talk about them."
So sometimes I think it's helpful for us
to voice those things and to be able
to correct those misperceptions,
whether they're intentional
or unintentional and then
help us all think about ways
to move forward.
So I'm just curious, as
you've been interacting
with students, if there
are certain misconceptions
about either spiritual
practices or mental health
that you've had to confront
in a gentle and loving way
to help students move to a better place.
And they're just principles we can apply
from those things going forward.
So Sharon, would you be willing
to just start with that?
- Sure.
I'm always very candid with students
that I'm not a therapist and
that I will share with them
when they're saying something
that is making me frightened
for them, that again,
I won't abandon them.
If I feel like we need extra support here,
we need to go over, walk
over to mental health
and counseling, I'll stay with them.
But I have found what's changed over time,
and this really isn't
related to the pandemic,
I think it's the time that we're in,
is that it's a lot easier to
talk about mental health issues
with students from across many religious
and spiritual communities.
And I can remember a time
when it wasn't so easy
and that there was a lot of shame involved
if it was ever kind of a conversation
about sharing a diagnosis
with a family member
or a family member having a diagnosis
and then the student processing that
and not really knowing what to do with it.
That has really changed
and changed for the better.
And so now you can have these
conversations with a student.
Let's say they have a counselor
and they're not comfortable
with that person.
You can say, "Well, if you
didn't like your dentist,
you would change your dentist.
You want what's best for your teeth,
well, you want what's best
for your mental health."
So when I first do a few
screening questions to find out
is the fact that they
don't like the experience,
does it have to do with the fact
that they don't feel better yet?
And is that the therapist's fault
or is that part of the process?
So you kind of have to do a
little mining around that,
and I'm not sure if
this is getting exactly
to your question, but I
know that I'm just getting
a lot more frank with students
when we talk about this.
And the difference
between a mental illness
and a time of mental anguish or distress,
whether it be from bad
news or a broken heart
or something like that
that's the stuff of life
and making a distinction between the two
so that they can get the best help
and also understand that
they can survive it.
- Yeah, I think that's really helpful.
I mean, even as someone
who's not a mental health professional
to help the students
identify that as well,
because that's something that students
and all of us can struggle with at times,
when there is that mental
anguish or something that happens
in the moment and really
trying to distinguish
between those 'cause I think...
And this has come up in
other episodes before,
there has been healthier
language around mental health,
but sometimes I think
it does get confusing.
So even we had Victoria Garrett
who's a former D1 athlete
trying to really encourage
people when they say
that they're feeling depressed,
but then also trying to think about,
well, are they really depressed
or is it something in the moment?
And is it something to have...
Always need to have the
tools to walk through those
versus trying to pull
in and get extra help.
So the fact that the students
are aligning to be frank
in those conversations, I
think it's really healthy
in a lot of ways and very encouraging.
- Yeah, I think it is.
And I think we've seen this
also from the Olympic athletes
who are naming what they're going through
and normalizing that
and naming their needs
and normalizing the language in such a way
that I think young people
will look at that and go,
"Oh, that isn't quite
what I thought it was."
And they're okay.
And other things happened
and that's okay too.
I think all of that is to the good.
- Yeah, definitely.
And then as you mentioned,
having the openness to say,
okay, you can walk them
down to a mental health
and counseling and there's not shame
that should be associated with that,
that it's just part of the process.
And we should all be thinking
about getting the help
that we need for whatever
we might be going through
at any specific point in time,
whether it's just the
anguish of a situation
or something that's
much more all consuming.
So that's encouraging
for me to hear as well.
- Yeah.
- Definitely.
Omer, anything that you've run into
or noticed with the students
that you've been working with?
- Sure.
And thank you, Sharon for setting that up.
In fact, one of the things
that I wanna talk about,
which was related to that
is there was a new study
that was just published in
JAMA Psychiatry last week
that got a lot of press.
NPR did a story on it,
and it got national press.
It was out of Stanford and
really quickly the summary of it,
and it was very relevant
to this is that they found
that the American Muslim
community is twice as likely
to have attempted suicide
as compared to other
religious communities.
And then it was a
fascinating study and article
that delved into the reasons.
They said there's really
two factors, right?
One is religious discrimination,
the toxic, corrosive effects
of Islamophobia and xenophobia
on these communities.
And the second is community stigma.
And that's where I wanna connect
with what Sharon was saying
is that, all of our communities
in their respective ways
have had stigmas against mental
health and talking frankly
about these conversations.
And I think one thing
that has happened now
is that our community
is, at least my community
in particular, I'll just talk about this,
is finding the door is opening, right?
Where we're reaching crisis
levels of the corrosive effects
of this stigma.
And so we need to start talking about this
and I really wanna applaud the people
who participate in this.
I know the director that
ran the study at Stanford,
wonderful female scholar, Dr. Rania Awaad,
and just really from our
community and then looking outward
is pulling the curtain
back on these stigmas
because it's something
that our students, right,
and connect to the...
The second thing I want to say is that,
for the longest time, our
students haven't wanted
to talk about these things,
but maybe it's just something
with the pandemic,
is it opened up conversation doors, right?
And one of the things,
and to Sharon's point
about just being frank,
I really love the way you framed that,
is I wanna say this;
is that we understand Yale
is a high octane place.
The type of people that come to Yale,
the type of people that excel at Yale,
it's all about excellence.
It's a lot being the best
from the faculty to the staff,
to the students, to the athletes and on.
And so it becomes actually,
I think, very problematic
in that, that coupled with
this idea of the grind
and hustle culture, right?
Is that like, what am I doing
on my Tik Tok and my IG?
How is it part of my brand
and furthering my place in the world?
And I think our students are
really susceptible to that.
And some of the frank conversations
I had with my students
is like, "That's not our real..."
We all need to learn to
dial it down and to be real.
There's a performativeness
that is almost fetishized,
I think, amongst our society now,
and especially at these high
pressure cookers like Yale
and that, I think, one of the...
It's a negative, but it's a breakthrough
that I think I had with some students
or that students have
themselves, I should say,
is that they're just like,
yeah, that's not sustainable.
That's not gonna be sustainable
through the pandemic.
And I don't know if it's gonna
be sustainable afterward.
So, if they're able from
that negative experience
to walk and to say that
I need to dial it down,
hey, that's a win, right?
So yeah, that's something I put out there.
- That's great.
That's great.
And something that I
think is still applicable,
even in the broader sense,
and as you're talking about
I'm thinking if that framework
can perpetuate how powerful
that can be to really just
shift things across culture.
And I'm curious to hear that
you've had those conversations
in a lot of ways and the
openness is definitely important.
And even as, I mean, you
mentioned the first challenge
with all the Islamophobia and xenophobia
that obviously still has to be addressed,
but I'm encouraged that the
conversation is happening
and those other pieces are
much bigger conversations
than we're having here,
but it'd be great to see,
on both sides, if we can really
do that across the board.
But again, I feel like
I'm repeating myself.
I'm grateful for just the
way that you all are engaging
with students and just
all that's coming out
of that already, which I think
is really powerful and impactful.
Orlando, anything you wanted
to add in your interactions
with your students in your
sphere of influence as well?
- Yes, I think one kind
of misunderstanding
or even missed opportunity
is in recognizing the overlap
between community care in health
and individual care and health,
as it relates to mental health.
And students, in my experience,
are more open to speaking
about what's happening
for them individually
and requesting things individually.
But students won't necessarily
talk with each other
as much as I think they could
benefit if there was more
of a community of support
in a community of care.
And one of my challenges is
saying, okay, how can I support
what's happening at the individual level
and in an appropriate way, and
in a way that can be healing
to allow the community
aspect to come together.
So that's something that I'm working on.
So I think there seems to be not a stigma
with being transparent one on one,
but perhaps still a stigma
with being transparent
in more of a group setting.
So that's one thing that I'm experiencing
and thinking about.
And the other piece is,
with students do want help,
they're asking me to help
them to find specialists
who look like them and have
their faith background,
or that even as they're going
through a treatment process
or care process, they
are not directed away
from their values.
And so that has presented
me with an opportunity
to try to see, okay, who are
individuals who may relate
with students and do
some vetting in a way.
And I found that it is not easy.
It is not easy.
Like I don't have a huge
large pool to choose from.
What does help is the
opportunity of virtual support?
So maybe there's a larger
network than just who was in,
let's say New Haven or Connecticut,
but might be able to connect
students with professionals
who were in their own
hometown or home country
and to be able to do that.
So I think those are two areas,
be more of a community support
and having mental health
to be a community process and focus,
and then also helping students to be okay
with who I walked them to
in terms of getting
more professional help.
And those are two areas
that I need to grow in,
that I'm trying to train in right now,
so that I'm better equipped
and I have more of a network
of professionals around
me as we dive into this
for this particular year and beyond.
- Yeah.
Yeah, that's really important
and I'm glad you brought that
to the forefront as well.
Something that the field has
been grappling with for a while
in a lot of ways is just
making sure that people are...
The phrase people use is
to have cultural competency
in terms of what background they have
and even the faith traditions.
I mean, I think the mental
health field has moved forward
in a lot of ways.
I think and Sharon, you
mentioned this before,
even within the mental health field,
I think in the past there was
a tendency to be dismissive
about people's cultural
experiences and to be dismissive
about the faith journeys.
Whereas now, there is
more of a push to say,
no, we really need to think
about people as whole people
and not pretend that
those things aren't part
of people's lives and that portends
that even despite all the
research and the evidence,
so end up being members of communities
and faith communities in general,
it can have both positive
and negative effects
on people's mental health,
depending on how that's approached.
But you can't just dismiss the
whole thing and remove that.
And as people of faith here
who believe in the power of bad
to work through these things,
that needs to be integral as well.
But to your point, Orlando,
it's still difficult for people
to get connected with the resources
because the resources
aren't what they need to be.
So kudos to you for doing that homework.
But in some ways, it also
reflects on the system
that you have to do that
homework in the first place,
and that's not readily available.
That's something we're still
definitely moving forward with.
And just to say, if your students
want access to resources,
they can definitely reach out to me
and I can put them in touch with folks.
Several of the guests who
have come on this podcast
have focused on that in particular.
And so I think it's an ongoing
and important conversation.
Again, just appreciate your
transparency in sharing that
'cause it's really, really
important and critical.
And again, I keep harping back to this,
but you all are on the
front lines in so many ways
and really encouraging and
empowering the students
in those conversations and
normalizing it as well.
I know we used normalizing
in different ways,
we can't get back to
normal that we had before,
but we can continue to
normalize these conversations.
And it sounds like you all are
doing that in so many ways.
The time always goes fast on this podcast,
but I did want to wrap up just
by talking about the vision
that you all have for
the year going forward.
And vision in a sense of hopes and dreams.
Maybe not in the sense
of specific strategies,
'cause we've already made
sure that that's not agnostic,
that that's not the case here.
But yeah, just your vision for yourselves
and for the students
as they're coming back.
And not to throw too many
questions in at once,
but as we've been talking,
I've also been thinking
about all three of you and just
your own emotional wellness
as you are carrying and walking
through with the students.
And that can be a load
and a burden sometimes,
not that it's meant to be a burden,
but just hoping that
you all have this space
for your own self care as well.
And it sounds like you
have that in community,
but I'm just curious, as
you talk about vision,
if there's space for you to
even talk about how you envision
that for yourself as well.
So that was a very loaded
and very compound question.
So I feel bad calling
on anyone to go first,
but I'm going to anyway.
Omer, would you be willing to jump in?
- No, I really appreciate
the questions in that.
And so what I would say is two things.
One is that just the return to community
and to just be honest about
what that's going to look like,
that we're gonna phase it in,
but the goal is ultimately, God willing,
to move to a more connected community.
I think that we can be authentic
and honest with our students, right?
With our humanities, not just students.
Because that way we manage expectations.
So my vision is that we're
gonna emerge from this wizened
and in many ways with
a deeper appreciation
for the things that we missed,
that we've missed out on
that we lost in one sense.
And then in terms of the other thing
that I would say is I think that...
There's a saying, right,
every chapel would need the chaplain.
And so I am so deeply grateful
for Sharon and Orlando
and yourself and just
friends and colleagues
that are in these spaces
that do this work,
that at least for me helped me process it
because I am an obsessive reader of news.
Unfortunately, I'm a news junkie.
And the world is a very
difficult, in many ways,
heartbreaking place and
if we get tunnel vision
as you get sucked into that,
it is so disheartening.
So I think the ability to be
able to process it with friends
and loved ones and to just
really talk it through,
that to me is just like
been a saving grace.
And I think helps us keep all our sanity
and our sort of mental
health and spiritual health.
- Agreed. Agreed.
Well, I appreciate you
talking that through
with us today too 'cause
it's been encouraging
and in some ways, eye opening
for me as well, just to hear,
again, just the pieces
that you all have been walking
through with your students.
Orlando, what about you?
- Yes, I'm thinking about two things.
One, values and gifts.
So in terms of values, what
are our community values
that we can lean into at this time?
And what are I individual values
that I can help encourage students
to lean in to at this time?
So even if it's not...
Even if a strategy is not quite clear
or a program is not quite
clear, we can have a matrix
upon which or through
which we make decisions.
And that matrix can be our
collective and individual values.
Now, the challenge is,
with every new semester
and with every new school year,
the population of students changes.
And with that, there may
come differences in values
or maybe not, but I think I'm
still gonna have to go through
the process of saying, "Okay,
well, what are our values
and how can lean into them?"
One, so that we are sure where we stand,
but also so that we can let
other people know where we stand
and be more of an inviting community.
And then that will allow
us, especially on my end,
to have values-based collaboration.
So for Orlando to do
what Orlando can do well,
and then for me to broaden
the network of who our members
and students can reach out
to and be in community with.
So that community...
One blessing of the pandemic
is that our identity
is not tied to a place, is not
tied to a physical location,
is not tied to an address,
it's not even tied to a time zone.
So how can we think more
broadly and more inclusively
about who we are and who we can be
in relationship to one another?
And if we can start to identify
and choose what values we want,
I think that will help with collaboration
and deepening community.
And then the other
piece in terms of gifts,
I think there's healing in the body.
And I think that everything
we need is in the house.
And I think about God's house.
But I think there are enough gifts.
I think that there are enough strengths
in who we are collectively
that when any one of us
leans into those strengths,
but at the same time, we
really can bring a lot of hope,
bring a lot of healing,
bring a lot of positive transformation
to everyone with whom we are connected.
I know one of my gifts is
exhortation and exhortation
is a time for now or now is
the time for exhortation.
So I'm trying to say, "Okay,
how can I lean into who I am?
And for people who have other strengths,
how can I encourage them to
lean in to those strengths?"
And BCAY is a student-run
church and students,
as they're young adults beginning,
they don't always recognize
what their strengths are,
what their gifts are, and what
the gem is that they bring
to their families or those around them.
And some who do recognize
it, don't believe it.
And a question I have is, Orlando, okay,
how can I help raise
for them the opportunity
to see that not only are they
a part of a larger community,
but they are a valuable
part of a larger community?
And not based on how they perform,
but based on who they are at
their core and what they value
and what they see.
And I think that's a challenge
that I wanna lean into
as we go into this year,
to celebrate gifts of what
people bring to the table
and also to lift up values
to see if we can be more collaborative
and expand our definition of community.
- That's so good.
So many important pieces there.
I mean, just the value component as well,
and the strengths that students can bring
to encourage one another.
And in some ways, I'm speculating
here, but I have a sense
that that's something
that you all are doing
in your role in the
chaplain's office as well,
even the way you talked
about leaning on one another,
people stepping in,
that people have a sense
of their values and their
strengths and their gems,
and are able to use those
to encourage the whole body
within the chaplains organization.
So to see that amongst
your students as well,
goes such a long way.
And even from, I'm thinking just in terms
of a mental health perspective,
some of the mental health interventions,
they're really focused on perspective.
What is actually happening in the world
versus how do I perceive
that and really shifting that
to make sure that
perceptions master reality.
And so if the students are getting a sense
of their true value in
having that perception,
how powerful that can
be to moving forward,
not that it solves everything,
but having that appropriate
and fixed perspective in the
same way that we can do that
through reading holy scriptures
and things like that,
to reshape our perspective,
what does God say about us
and how do we use that to
then interact with the world
and think about ourselves?
So, yeah, just encouraged by the framing
that you've put there and for
all that you all are doing.
Sharon, to give you the last
word, to wrap all this together
with these great comments
from Omer and the Orlando.
- Well, I'm humbled by my
beloved preaching brothers.
(laughing)
I won't be anywhere near as eloquent,
but I will honestly say my
vision is blurry for the future,
but I am fueled by grace.
- Honest.
- That I know.
I have an abiding faith
that that is present
and I hope to embody it in forms
of compassion and kindness,
and how to sustain that for ourselves
so that we can continue to
do this work really has to do
with, in many ways, knowing your limits,
knowing that you are called to be present,
but you aren't called to fix.
And so to not look away,
to lead with kindness
and compassion and know that the rest
is really out of our hands.
But I feel grateful for my colleagues.
I feel grateful for my family.
And I know that (laughing)
the impact of this work
is something we won't see (laughing)
and that I came to terms
with that years ago.
And there's a lightness to
that that I think is healthy
to keep in mind, especially
at a place like Yale,
where there's lots of talk about legacy
and impact and all these things.
I can't do the work with that in mind.
I do the work the present and
hope that those seeds lead
to a better world.
- Such good wisdom.
- Agreed. Agreed.
Well, thank you to all of you
for this rich conversations,
it was very edifying in a lot of ways.
Even as we're walking through
these challenging times,
even with the uncertainties
to know just the power of community
and the power of knowing our
value and knowing our worth
and having others who are
walking through that with us,
I think goes so far and it'll be important
for all of us across the
country as we're heading back
into this new semester with
so many different aspects
of what we haven't experienced before.
So again, grateful to the
work that you all are doing,
grateful for your willingness
to share this with our audience.
I know it's gonna be something
that will be enriching
and a blessing to them as well.
Thank you again for taking
time out of your schedules,
even as you're getting
close to the semester start
to come here and have this conversation.
I'm deeply appreciative.
- Okay, thank you.
- Thank you.
Thank you so much, Nii.
- Thank you, Nii.
(upbeat music)